When you've been locked up
for 100 hours,
chained,
on the brink of death.
and you've lost
your best friend.
Those 100 hours
feel like 100 years.
And going outside...
is the biggest freedom
in the world.
Regardless of being aimed at
by thousands of soldiers.
Unarmed,
barefoot,
with the sun on your face,
surrounded by silence...
you feel free.
We were sending
a message of hope.
Lisbon was there...
with us.
Walking out of the bank.
Not at the National Court
nor in prison,
like everyone thought.
Colonel Tamayo!
White flag!
We were telling them...
that if we were capable
of doing that...
we would be capable
of doing anything.
And people began
to believe in miracles.